[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
we are streaming live in the br app from
the beautiful wing golf course here in
las vegas nevada and we are less than 90
minutes away from getting to see these
guys next to me tee off in the match on
tnt
[Music]
what's going on guys i'm jj watt and i'm
here with four quarterbacks you may
know a little bit
from the tampa bay buccaneers we have
world champion tom brady i think like 19
times or something
from the green bay packers we have aaron
rodgers
from the kansas city chiefs we have
patrick mahomes
[Applause]
and from the buffalo bills we have josh
allen
and i mean i like that
they travel well they travel well they
travel well i'm paying them well too
josh signed a monster contract last year
it's like in like the first quarter
right there and by the fourth quarter
it's really quiet so this is
as you can see we have started the trash
talk hot and heavy early here it's been
going on for a few weeks these guys have
been going at it and today we finally
get to settle the score
how are we feeling guys how we feeling
i feel good me and pat we've played a
lot of holes together not these guys so
much so
we're feeling good you're attacking them
as a team already yes
guys how's the camaraderie between the
two
it's been great
i feel relaxed this is a uh peanut
butter and jelly right here so
should be a great day i know we got two
great
challengers and uh young studs
and uh it's gonna be tough it's it's got
a great course out there but i got a
great partner so i think i know how it's
gonna go in the end when they got rid of
the pros
you know i thought they'd pick some
competent golfers
and then i saw the match-up
i'm just worried because i saw these
guys golfing a little earlier and i
don't know how old they are if they can
play an extra 12 holes oh ooh
tom you're
one and one in these or
0-2 okay so you haven't won one of these
yet right got it got it a lot like you
versus me
all right all right changing today all
right gentlemen we're gonna settle it in
we're gonna settle it in here's how this
press conference is going to work i will
be up here asking the questions but i
will purely be a conduit from the fans
to you fans you guys can submit your
questions in the chat now i have an ipad
here and i will be asking the questions
of the gentleman up here so we have the
first question we're going to start off
easy and and we'll see we'll see where
it goes uh first question from at
jblair5
how often do you guys play golf we'll
start with tom and work our way down
uh not as often as when i was their age
kids and just
training for football kind of got in the
way of all that so i would say
and i was in the northeast for 20 years
so there's not there's a small season so
maybe um once
two or three times a month if i'm lucky
two or three times a month two or three
times a month how about in this last
month i've hit 7 000 golf balls in the
last three days
at least
it's gonna be uh it's not from lack of
effort in this final stage of cramming
for the test all right aaron i play
about
once a month
once a month that's a lie that does not
seem correct
that's a lie that's true on average
on average about 12. what have you
played in the last 30 days i played 30
holes yesterday and i played a few this
morning and that is already more than
once a month pat how many times
do you play yeah um
i used to play more i have the baby now
so i don't get to play as much
but i try to get out there once a week
in the off season at least and get some
work in um hit some long drives hope
hope they're straight um and uh see what
happens but you live on a golf course
right
yeah i do that for the clubhouse the the
amenities that they have
you don't live on a clubhouse in green
bay on a golf course it's there
we got two great courses
we can't come at wisconsin tom you got
two boys up here i love wisconsin all
right jj all right josh i go off too
much to not be as good as i should be
for golfing that much
a lot my mind's in a blender
think about the question
think about that whatever he's been
working on he's been working on a lot
lately so all right i think he looks
ready to go he's he's buttering you up
killing me for butter
yeah catch more bunny i get it bunnies
with honey i don't know uh next question
from
jt456 this one's a layup what is your
favorite pizza toppings
tom do you eat pizza time doesn't eat
pizza do you eat some sort of vegan
flatbread an apple cauliflower pizza
no comment no comment all right
aaron i don't need people i mean you
think about something here
ourselves everybody cheers pepperoni
pizza
pepperoni mushroom artichoke
crushed peppers jalapenos you can tell
josh looks like a josh yeah everything
on it
all right my goodness we lost some
viewers there with hillary clinton
sausage
uh next question better questions jj
i'm the reading for the fans so if
you're gonna crap on the questions
you're coming at the fans so let's keep
it off my head at j radovitz oh this
this should be good let's start from
this end this time
josh what is your spirit animal and why
a spirit animal
golden retriever
man a buffalo bill would have been a
strong answer there
you know would have been a really crowd
pleaser but golden retriever okay
pat
i'm a wolf i'll just say i'm i'm you
know the leader of the pack
i got my guys with me uh today my guy is
josh allen we're gonna go out there and
get this dub you guys two in the wolf
pack and then then there was three
and then we added tom as the fourth in
wolf pack right tom
erin
i'm gonna say a dolphin
why
if you know about the uh
mating patterns of a dolphin yeah
do they migrate from tampa down the
coast or where do they start i don't
know how it works they're all over the
world oh yeah oh sometimes they have to
turn around and go back to where they
came from but they have a lot of
pleasure in their life that's just
checking
uh all right next
you know oh sorry tom sorry tom i
thought it was a dolphin too i didn't
know i think uh a cheetah
because i just resemble so much of what
i do when i see myself run out there on
the field it's like a cheetah
it's actually interesting you say that
yeah i i was handed some statistics
before this press conference and they
they had the
the slowest times in nfl history
and uh there are three people slower
than you last season
do you would you like to take a guess i
like to consider playing speed is
different than 40 speed so we could all
attest to roethlisberger was one i'll
give you that so you outran he was old
burger he was all you're older i think
i'm not 100 sure okay but you do have a
lot of first downs i think you have a
thousand career rushing yards so that's
something to be proud of a lot of
quarterback sneaks man yeah
congratulations lugo dog dog i'm not a
big quarterback snake guy anymore
yeah
no it's smart all right uh josh this
one's for you from jack sawyer33
josh is it true that you throw up before
every game and if so will you do it
today
i do throw up before every game
and
if i can if as long as i might take
aaron to the side and let him can you
throw up right now that would be great
for ratings no you probably could no if
i start thinking about it i get a little
queasy so so seriously after you throw
up do you eat again no i don't eat game
days you don't play every morning i
don't eat if we
play at night i'll eat a little
breakfast
wait wait wait wait wait a second wait a
second there's some counseling probably
wait a second yeah a 7 p.m game you're
eating a little breakfast light
breakfast and then throwing it up and
then that's it throw up then take my
little calf like my uh my little red
pre-workout drink before the game's
ready to go whoa we're going to have
some nutrition
pat what do you eat before games
i'm a big just uh steak and eggs guy
with a little bit of potatoes you know
what i'm saying get a little carbs get a
lot of ketchup in there for sure yeah
it's embarrassing
but uh i'm not a big throw up guy yeah
so i'm about to leave that to josh not
big on the throw up erin pre-game meal
pizza
pizza
me too
this is this side of the table is me
lovers pizza hoot over here
uh all right next question from mr
crispy 65
this is just going to throw me into the
middle of a
[ __ ] storm here which you can throw the
football the furthest
i mean
me jj
nope wow i've seen all these guys it's
not me i've seen all these guys just
throw it launch it i saw it aaron
throwing in the game that's first i've
ever seen rolling to his left must been
74 yards in the air they got called for
a pi detroit
so at home going left to right there's a
little bit of tailwind i don't know i
don't care 74 in the air is impressive
tailwind in detroit no in green bay oh
okay
no no in green bay versus detroit it was
ridiculous though tom how far are you
throwing it now
uh max as far as you need to yeah i mean
i could i could get out there pretty far
far enough okay great great answer
method you know yeah and very
impliability all
all right we're gonna start back with
tom on this one uh this one's from at
trey young stan
tom guess your playing partner's biggest
fear
biggest fear
oh man
golfing fear or like life life life here
oh man that's tough
you should have prepped us that for that
one earlier haircuts you could say here
things yeah yeah definitely that i think
just agreeing with everyone all the time
is probably his biggest fear he's
went to cal berkeley they like to take
typically a very different stance than
the rest of everyone else my sister went
there i love cal
but um you know a lot of cal graduates
that are good smart with the sister
there smart to bring it back it's true
parker campus all the athletes tom's
biggest fear
tom's biggest fear is probably that guy
in kentucky
watching
one of his documentaries who doesn't
want to buy a tb12 sports shirt
the guy that's out of sports.com not
very pliable tom's fear is lack of
playability
uh patrick vegan protein josh's biggest
fear jj likes protein big fan big fan of
protein awesome big fan thank you josh
josh's biggest fear
vegetables a coin toss
that's a good answer
josh that wasn't for josh that's all
these bills fans out here vision from
within this is starting well division
from within that we're on the same page
you know what get him back pat's biggest
fear is let me down on the course today
that's his biggest fear that's a golden
retriever
i love it he's trying to get my head and
his teammate the golden retriever is
coming out get down on your knees josh
come on let's spice this up a little bit
come on
i mean you're not gonna like this if you
want spice uh french toast or pancakes
josh
tom's gonna say both for you so get it
out of the way i don't think he's that
fat with whipped cream waffles he was
really can i choose waffles jj
sure not not an option but go for it
all right i'm not big on either but i
would say french toast if i had to pick
okay pancakes peanut butter syrup
all right waffles
all right
anything on top of the waffles just
syrup and a little butter all right a
little avocado butter or whipped cream a
little strawberry butter i go for it
okay all right this is
this is groundbreaking guys this is
groundbreaking tom brady eats butter put
it on a billboard
the next question does not come from a
fan it comes from a former teammate of
mine somebody who now resides here
in las vegas i believe so let's go to
the video
what's up everybody welcome to vegas
you're here with chandler jones with the
las vegas
my question for you guys i was wondering
uh what are you guys most excited about
to do here in vegas what are you guys
most excited about
the question is what are you guys most
excited about to do here in vegas
besides the golf match obviously
well that's why we're here so i think
i'm most excited to get out there and
you know test our skills under pressure
see if the young bucks can keep up with
the two old bulls
and um you know i know it's going to be
a tight match but that's why we're here
we're here to win it's a business trip
pure business trip
all right let's go to the next question
tom
keeping it straight great answer tom
great answer you're great keeping it
just locked in thank you uh from ryan
patrick 27 i i don't even know
if i would know the answer place myself
what cologne do you each wear i mean
where are we going here guys i don't
wear cologne i can tell
josh it's a it's tom ford i forget the
name of it wow nice wow smells good good
choice good job
i know you're a tom ford guys
because of you
get over it uh did you forget your name
or they just
put it on there
just to remind you boys a little bit
okay yeah okay
bradybrand.com
aaron what typically are we wearing
today what i i've lost uh control ysl
ysl didn't see that coming i'm not gonna
lie
tom first real answer i've given i
thought aaron would have been like a
very natural
i thought so too all eco-friendly
deodorant is soap is paraben free very
earthy no sulfates and just toss the ysl
on top of it love it yup tom
it's a personal question jj i know not
uh talked about my personal answers oh
no no absolutely that's the whole reason
i'm here they said that i could ask the
personal questions what does gizelle
pick out for you to wear
is it sold on tb12sports.com
tb12 didn't have a phone yet are you not
paying you yes you're not being paid by
a clone company so you can't say the
answer i understand how you can go to
cb12 sports after the match and buy the
shirt
that tom is wearing today he'll sign it
if you're lucky
uh all right next question from raw
dreams
all right
which is the db you hate playing against
the most tom
it's been nba i hate playing against
22 years what do you think 24 25 in my
history or just this history
ed reed
yeah ed reed ed reed was
show if you haven't seen him go watch
them the guy was unbelievable and uh
yeah played as good as any secondary
play in history ed reed great player
aaron
i'm gonna say a guy who i would put up
there right with him is is uh charles
woodson
charles was the best player i played
with and
gave me fits when i was working on the
on the scout team every week what do you
pick you off in practice
oh yeah and then he'd run the ball right
to you and hand it back to you love it
pat uh probably jalen ramsey i'd
probably say for me
a pretty good guy pretty good player
fast big pretty good loves to talk a
little trash too so
pretty good player yeah he's a pretty
good player josh tredavious white of the
buffalo bills all right there you go
there's your teammate bump gotta love it
gotta love it love that guy homer
um all right i like this one i know
josh's answer mr pop tart head asks if
you could change one nfl rule what would
it be
it's the unsportsmanlike conduct rules
let the guys celebrate let them do
whatever really whatever they want not
the coin toss we already changed it
nevermind jj get with the times you
idiot
uh all right unsportsmanlike rules i
like it pat what are you changing i
would say offensive targeting i want to
lower my head when i when i run the
football
every rule off of you forever offensive
targeting lead with your head no the
hardest part let's have this
conversation guys
do quarterbacks deserve less protection
i don't think we do necessarily i think
you do
stronger strongly
ah deserve is a tough word
should you have less hunters do kickers
do holders do ah you guys have more
disagree i think you have way more
i respectfully this i will stand up for
every defensive player you guys that you
can't even get cut anymore
yes you can
you can still get cut you don't even
know what's going on down in the
trenches no idea you can't even backpack
you don't have any idea that we can
still get our knees just wiped out from
under us but i can't graze my hand
across your head
and i know i've done it i've gotten big
big fines for it
all right let's go back to the press
conference
uh from smart pig which of the four has
the worst sense of style
josh
just look at him oh don't point at me
josh can't even get short that's true
i don't need the style points
i'm good with it i'm going to stay out
of this one oh man close my eyes and
definitely whatever's in the closet
all right gosh josh is taking that on
the chin i respect it uh from matt 2007
tom's eighth year in the league tom will
you ever retire
yes i thought he already retired yeah
good question
really good question there i've done
that already
um okay
from digger2236
who has hit or sacked you the hardest
josh
you've hit me pretty hard thank you
there we go good answer let's move on no
but that's not my answer that's not my
answer it was actually against the
texans though it was merciless and
clowny come in and
fair enough got my elbow pretty good get
rid of the damn ball josh slide
the ball
back when i was in college when i used
to run um i came around the corner and
quandary digs put me to sleep so i would
say that would be the biggest one no you
still run you just run backwards like 15
yards and then yeah i don't run where i
can get hit yeah run yeah it sucks yeah
no i know smart
aaron julius peppers
if you've been hit by julius before you
remember it big boy yeah
legend absolute legend tom
uh this is a blast on the pass to be on
nfl throwback instagram this one you
guys but he was a buffalo bill at
buffalo nate clements
running it's like one yard behind the
line of scrimmage
i slid late my helmet went about 10
yards back and uh check it out on
youtube that film's black and white
right youtube
black and white
sorry
films in black
it's hard to see it's like there's a
film but you're going to see the helmet
go
he doesn't know what that he doesn't get
that reference
i don't understand what that is i have
no clue that's history that was a class
that we all went to history yeah in
elementary school when they skip your
class yeah they learn about youtube
is that a good one no we'll talk but
we'll talk okay we'll explain you on the
course
all right okay do you like apples
smartpak
old man jokes that jokes are here so all
right i'm going to move on to the next
question i missed the apple juice thank
you jj
tom 600 years old
there's a movie
go ahead go now you go ahead go ahead
give the people the history lesson just
just fill them in i forgot okay
uh from nick foliage what flavor chicken
wings do you like best
hot
that's it
uh barbecue
or garlic parmesan all right i don't eat
chicken wings this is this is just off
the rails
what impossible chicken wing flavor do
you like no comment no comment what have
you eaten today tom
what was your breakfast today i don't
eat for the love of goodness tell the
people what you've eaten today
do you eat food
do not say a tb12 electrolyte packet i
don't want to hear it
have you eaten
real food i gotta i can handle it thank
you if you want to know what tom ate
today he's gonna post it later on
tv12sports.com
that's tb sports number 12
dot com thank you
mike thanks aaron this is absurd
uh all right michigan packer fan that
doesn't even make sense but uh what is
your favorite disney movie
moana
great it's a good one great movie great
music great message
lion king lion king classic tarzan
tarzan
lilo and stitch
you kind of look like one of them i
don't know which one but you can look
like this is badass
uh
ryan over here all right this is a good
question topical uh that's going on in
the world right now
celtics are warriors who's going to win
the world wow that's really hard
um yeah we know you're not going to get
my favorite teams i mean it's hard to
choose i hate predictions yeah we know
yeah i'm not predicting yeah but i i
steph curry is amazing and warriors are
gonna you know i think the word is
pretty amazing but but between the two
who do you think will score the more
points
tom you don't play there anymore you can
say it it's fine
no i love the celtics i really do you
don't play there anymore though yeah i
love the celtics do you think they'll
score more points than the warriors
i think the words are kind of i want to
know what he thinks where is there later
on
do i have to watch a drone shot of you
taking a golf ball and hitting it to the
moon and then the moon explode into your
prediction is that how i'll learn
i like that
who's going to win somebody
right now or go with the celtics
you are being attacked yep it's pretty
easy to attack a guy with seven super
bowl rings because he can win any
argument so
we'll attack all day uh from we three
this is a good question i'm actually
curious why is tom the only one wearing
pants
gentlemen sport obviously there's one
gentleman up here
it's two gentlemen up here i don't know
if they're kind of i don't know those
pants
guys it's between you guys floods are
coming tomorrow the gentleman's sport
and i figured i'd bring a little you
know got the high ones
that's what ben hogan would wear
this actually got no cabs two words
varicose veins
[Laughter]
oh
it's hot out here tom's got that's gross
is it gonna be a factor in the match yes
yes the heat it is warm are they brady
brand pants yeah okay they don't fit you
though they they uh yeah they're gonna
stay intact this time or what
it's hard
they stretch though so stretch though
this time i might get a 4xl for you yeah
that's fine make them longer too down
there
it's stylish josh should we talk about
your style not with this not the high
socks though
all right from at jamal i like these
josh we'll start with you my good luck
socks
what would your career be if you weren't
a football player
swimmer
[Laughter]
no yes
i'd be a swimming i love inside
in all reality i'd be a farmer
what kind of crops would i believe that
we got pistachios going in the answer
maybe tom can endorse some pistachios
for tb's why don't you invite me for
god's sakes invite me somewhere i'll
come okay pat's having a golf tournament
he didn't invite me aaron's never
invited me anywhere
so i uh it's an ota so i don't want to
invite y'all guys but they don't go to i
guess i could i feel left out they don't
go pat there's an ota today
yeah yeah but i'm sorry coach you get
like three or four you can just what
would you be if you weren't an nfl
player if i wasn't a nfl player hmm
um
i'd probably be an influencer
tick-tock like like aaron said it runs
in the family ah there you go sick dog
would you like to show a dance move
no no i would do like the how to's you
know like you had to make make something
in the kitchen maybe how to fix like a
lamp and i think it'd go viral i'd
follow that oh absolutely
aaron
uh shepard
shepard
tom
what would you be doing if you were an
nfl player tom that's my third goodwill
hunting reference okay so good
keep up what would i be yes um
what would i be
never thought about it okay that's tom's
seventh no answer of the night
why would i really get good stuff here
announcer commentator
we're doing that
i saw you're doing very well at it mike
job uh from at mitch5 what's the biggest
pet peeve about your teammate today
aaron start with you
he's distractingly good looking
appreciate it thanks tom feel the same
way about him that you guys are no fun
at press conferences good answer
feeling the flow
doing
um i would just say how good of a
football player he is
you know this it just just really is my
pet peeve of mine
awesome he he hits it further than me i
predict josh will start very fast and
then finish very slow
what
that could have gone a couple ways there
could have gone
that could have gone
[Applause]
yeah tom
thanks shane
thanks my brother that guy that guy
follows the tv 12 minutes my best
friend's 712. that guy let's see it hold
up one more
we go way back that's tv 12 minutes yeah
we've known each other since we're 12.
it's my best love it yeah uh all right
so you guys are always traveling
b12sports.com from eric24
what city in america has the best food
anybody kansas city
best barbecue in the world
good answer not buffalo
you got the best wings and that's not my
that's what josh said i'm a wings we're
hanging out over there we know yeah
we know blue cheese
so i'm wearing black today kind of
slimming smart very smart i like that
wings at the turn for you l.a
what what do you like
you got a lot of vegan options
yeah are you guys
yeah i didn't know that no i'm not okay
i just don't eat pizza only sometimes
except on game days
and then you throw it up no you don't
throw up it's a great way to shed a few
pounds before a show or a game
did you go vegan before you do a lot of
shows
what do you do a lot of shows i do
yes
all right
all right uh this is the longest hey
i do the longest hot seat i like this
thing like lucas is the longest hot tom
i do it on ten more
okay you haven't answered any questions
you haven't answered a single one of
them it's true i have a question jj for
you let's hear it go ahead tom you're
floor
did you accept doing this because gronk
said no
travis kelsey said no so i thank you
very much so i i didn't know uh gronk i
think is actually still in the pool from
the draft party he's still he's still on
property so i agree very possible just
uh
no i just want to get out of an ota so
i'm here
we couldn't leave you left out jj thank
you don't take that out against me on
christmas by the way when you pass what
are otas
exactly there you go there you go
uh who will win the mvp next
josh or patrick what a weird question
i can't hear anything you're saying who
will win the mvp next josh or patrick oh
great question guys can you grab tom's
hearing aid it's uh i think it's right
down there right it's a brady brand
brady brand tb12
um i would say josh he gets those
rushing yards man that dude's over there
jumping over hurdling people get those
highlights if aaron's going to give it
up at some point not just keep pointing
it
i think i think tom's
son wins mvp first
he's getting up because he's probably
he's about to be in the league right
yeah
how is he how is he as an athlete
uh what's his sport good he likes
everything yeah lacrosse love it
oh lacrosse good sport
uh okay i actually want to know the
answer to this one i'm very fascinated
to hear it
who is the most fun person you've ever
played golf with and if you could play
golf with somebody you've never played
with who would it be
tom someone i've never played golf with
that i'd love to play golf with yes and
who's your favorite person to play golf
with oh my dad my dad dad i love playing
with dad
uh golf um i feel like these two over
here will be pretty fun to play with and
i'm just thinking in the moment
i got you two
in my sights
think of them
it's a dreamforce it's amazing aaron
favorite person to play with
aj hawk all right
he's a blast he hits the ball kinda like
josh except it's way farther but it's
all over the place
smokes a cigar the entire time backwards
hat
uh
who would i want to play golf with
tiger that'd be great got to
got to um the favorite person i play
golf with obviously is travis
because by 16 he's hammered so you never
know what's going to happen
so he's he always starts off nice hit
him right down the middle of fairway and
then you get to the turn
starts getting worse you get the 15 16.
you don't know if you're playing golf
anymore
and then sometimes the club ends up in
the pond yeah i'll tell you about this
we'll tell the story about that the pawn
later all right all right
later
josh my favorite person my brother
and i read your note in the locker room
on the the locker inside the locker yes
i want to play with you you sound like
you have a fun time yeah no i have a
great time i see the whole course i
utilize every inch of grass it's a good
note too i don't even answer josh really
good answer tom he's on it
gentlemen
i appreciate the time i appreciate the
answers to the questions and playing
along and just being up here
uh but it's time for you guys to go to
the driving range all of you at home can
stick around and watch them on the
driving range here on the br app and
then head over to tnt to watch them
compete in the match
thank you for watching the hot seat
presented by capital one and then
tv12sports.com readybrand.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so we got time
thanks dad
look what mitch said
troy what's up with that
what's my idea yeah
nice to meet you man
we'll have some fun today oh yeah yes oh
you got your you know stretch out roll
out i know your voicemail hold out you
know that little low
back thank you for reminding me that
look at all these different utilities
there let's hit some shanks shall we
i'm so glad they put me way over here
all right
all right right pocket [ __ ]
[Music]
be very careful over here boys
you sure i'm gonna fit by a putter under
count yes thank you
so wait one two three us messed up we'll
probably yeah probably five
six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
thirteen yeah fourteen exactly 14.
perfect
i probably need this i'll be right back
just keep that for me i kind of want to
be the first one to head here
how far is
[Applause]
whatever pockets
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
did you get the sunglasses
[Applause]
how much time do we have i'm not trying
to hit here all day
you got like 40 minutes dude
are you going earpiece in right now i
mean they handed it to me i'm just gonna
throw it in and see what happens oh here
we go
left here
just keep it whatever it's gonna be left
yeah all right oh
that's weird
i got too many clubs right so i'm going
to hit that title
let's take that out you kidding me
so those and i gotta take
the four irons out too
right this one so that's four
five
six great divot that was uh
nine ten eleven twelve three fourteen
do you want me to put those
wow that's pretty
that was
can you do that in our practice 50
degree man can you do it under pressure
no probably not
[Applause]
eating broths
are we like hitting these into the water
i don't know i'm just hitting i don't
even know what's going on
i have a question
do they need to be talking and are you
right now can they cut that dead do you
hear them yeah
hey guys can we cut them off from our
ear while we're warming up that'd be
great
super loud
just yeah can you ask them yep you said
what now 178 on that flagship and i love
charles
that's what we're just talking about
okay
there we go
yep sounds good
yep you got me
a little warmer today
too forward
if i stay here for 40 minutes i'm going
to sweat through this shirt to be honest
with you yeah
yeah i got to do it how are you doing
i do not hear anybody thank you bull
that was a really good joke
who said that
i agree
pliable i got you ernie that's cause you
aaron all your antagonists how are you
doing
yep all right they're gone
over there
these are coming off good
yep i got you thank you how much is it
to the uh
yeah flag
like two fellas below that how you guys
doing
good to see you guys
over in the distant
feels pretty good today i'm not gonna
lie
i feel like there's uh aaron and i got
some good stuff working today so i feel
like we're gonna be good shape
i actually
thanks
yeah
i actually think it's
a great question
um actually it's gonna be really fun
because i think we all know each other
pretty well
and uh
you know we've all watched each other
for a long time and got to see each
other so it'll be a lot of fun banter
and it won't be you know world-class
golf so don't count on seeing that but
it will be fun golf
is that for me there am i both saying
hey hey aaron hey aaron sounds good you
guys talking a lot about the outfits i
can tell already your own outfit
yeah
charles is
right there i like it that looks good
high and volatile right the flag stick
i can hear you how y'all doing good one
don't say hey don't uh don't lose that
one there josh
how about that i'm saving them all for
the uh the course do it i don't think
you're gonna be able to do that again
yeah exactly that's all it's about out
here
oh [ __ ] a few sticks
aaron's got his alignment sticks all set
up
78 you said today
what's that name
[Music]
yeah
okay
all right let's get him out of the way
quick
bring them over for like jump on the
table or something come on make the
people happy if i hit a ball to the tee
box
real dangerous come on get crazy where's
the table you don't even get crazy
you seem like you get crazy but i bet
when it comes down to the moment josh
you don't
feel like you'd be really fun to bring
out and then you go home at like
midnight right
uh 11 30 11 30. weren't you the one that
was asleep at like 6 6 30 last night yes
i was on the east coast
out here practicing am i not the east
coast you're not here practicing i've
just been out here like
tom i've played doing interviews with
you guys 90 holes in the last two days
alone
over that flag have you yeah
it's not helping much i'll tell you that
i know
i think when you hit it really high like
that it's
yeah i like that
there we go that's not very controllable
you know that as well as i do nobody
hits the ball that high and controls it
that well that would be that's why you
drop it right beside the heart yeah i
saw him the last two days he just yeah
right right on the other fairways last
two days there's not been that i don't
like how serious aaron is over there
he's a little he's actually working on
something he's in the zone right now tom
those might touch right there there it
is they might touch
jackie what's up brother
hi [ __ ]
thank you over here he's taking care of
me all right say hi to silver nine bet a
couple part threes i was thinking
how are you doing
this is easy park getting past the other
stuff right hey kitty
how you doing
you know that mama
how are you doing good you have a good
day yep
thank you good luck oh it's good we're
gonna go hit it good it'll be fun it's
so fun they're so easy
it's very low uh
yeah very low key
plus i got the best part now that's
right that's right
that's right
well
12 was taken that's why 12
yeah 12 was a little retired there
that looked nice tom smooth
when i do retire
i'm going to play a lot more golf
a little shanky there
yeah
really cheese
do you have any teas i got a bunch you
got any cheesebee
i got a couple here
what's it to the front of the green
there
probably like can't hit the green from
there
who can't hit the green from there the
front of the green right right side
right because right where that ball is
at all right right with that ball
putting green in it yeah four five two
fourteen now okay top front corner okay
you try to get all the way 2 30 be tough
to get there but a nice flower
[Applause]
that's the sound of a mulligan somebody
moved that tree there breakfast ball
what are we doing at least
was hammered don't tell me nobody out
there does that
that ball gets stuck in the tree there
aaron
oh that's not great but it worked out i
bet
side bet
get two of these
that's her we got 30 minutes huh
let's get a long time at the end
oh let's see let's
right
six
you done sorry we didn't see that you
done you got my a couple yeah yeah i got
10 minutes of warm up that's what i'm
saying i know i'm thinking the same
thing you can hit driver at all
i'm about to hit three wooden driver and
then be done
i'll actually hit one
oh yeah i'll get something in a second
i'm gonna hit one foreign are you trying
to hit that little just case i want to
try to get frisky and go for something
play it how it plays my guy
sometimes it's just how it is
you got any pointers that on there hit
like that
hey i'm gonna talk a lot more [ __ ] than
i am hitting guard
so yeah don't worry about me hitting
good golf shots
yeah
okay so how far is it over here
oh
yep
leave it back there
oh no
oh no
oh
that was money though
all right one more one more drive
no sir that's to be put up
not off the ground
josh can you hit the waterfall yeah you
want me to i might hit the thing
where am i going right here
let me hit a couple more of those come
on 500 bucks if you get the waterfall
not great
it's not great
for a second there just one yeah it's
one free shot
what
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you